el inusual tiroteo en la frontera entre
Israel y Egipto causó la muerte desde
tres soldados israelíes y un policía
egipcio en un hecho que es considerado
uno de los más graves en estas frontera
desde la firma del acuerdo de paz de
1979 las fuerzas de defensa de Israel
reportaron que dos de sus soldados un
hombre y una mujer fueron asesinados en
mientras cubrían un turno en un puesto
de vigilancia fronterizo y sus cuerpos
fueron encontrados horas después luego
de que no respondieran a los llamados de
radio posteriormente mientras el
ejército israelí peina barazones se
produjo un nuevo intercambio de fuego en
el que murió un tercer agente israelí y
el oficial de policía egipcio eh fuentes
de ambas partes han indicado que se Está
realizando una investigación en total
cooperación para determinar las
circunstancias de lo ocurrido para
Israel no está claro como este oficial
cruzó la valla fronteriza ni por qué
razón Mientras que el ejército egipcio
ha indicado que el policía se encontraba
persiguiendo a narcotraficantes cuando
se produjo este tiroteo precisamente
hecho ocurrió horas después de que el
ejército israelí reportara haber
frustrado un intento de contrabando de
mercancías por 400 mil dólares Aunque el
portavoz militar israelí dijo que no hay
motivos para vincular los distintos
hechos Lo cierto es que estos
acontecimientos han sacudido una
frontera mayormente pacífica en la que a
veces suelen producirse disparos entre
oficiales israelíes y narcotraficantes o
persecuciones de policías egipcios a
narcotraficantes o a militantes
yihadistas en este escenario las
autoridades israelíes han determinado el
cierre de varias carreteras que conducen
a la frontera con Egipto mientras que
líderes regionales del neguev en Israel
han instado a sus residentes a mantener
la calma y a continuar con sus rutinas
habituales